mr. popular our new celebrity so many
great actors in this movie who aren't
with us anymore so yeah I am revisiting
the Harry Potter films every single one
of them which to date is 10 8 in the
main series and two fantastic beast
films um I'm not revisiting the books I
don't have the time to reread the books
but I do have the time to rewatch the
movies we're gonna go through I'm gonna
be releasing one of these every two
weeks and of course we must start with
Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone if
you live in a country where publishers
think you're dumb and the Philosopher's
Stone everywhere else the very first
Harry Potter film and this is an
interesting thing to go back to I have
to wonder how many people unless they
are you know my age and trying to
introduce their own kids into the thing
how many people actually go back and
watch the very first one it's a bit of
an odd beast especially in the wake of
the whole thing now being a finished
product it is a little bit clunky the
thing is I'm not sure there was a lot of
ways around that because this has a lot
to do like first there was a reason that
virtually no other you know based off of
you know teenage young teens aimed
fantasy book series trying to adapt into
a movies almost none of them got past a
first film you know we had so many false
starts you know there was Spiderwick
Chronicles and there was well as the
City of Bones and like there were there
were so many of these things like the
only one that got two sequels you know
before dystopian fiction took over was
was Chronicles of Narnia but that was
like that had name recognition
but my point is these openings are hard
because not only do you have to
introduce us to all these characters and
set up everything that we need to know
about this world in order to understand
anything that's going on you also have
to find a way to tell a story that's
actually interesting and worth telling
as you do all this stuff it's really
hard and it's actually especially hard
in film as opposed to the book because
while I haven't reread the book in a
while the book it gets to take its time
it gets to be more leisurely paced it
gets to introduce a lot more stuff just
through classroom scenes just through
very natural interactions between
characters whereas the film is stuck
dumping a lot of exposition into fewer
scenes because by its nature even over
two hours not everything not every scene
that was in the book can make the movie
so when you cut some you figure out crap
well there was this information that was
in that scene we now got to put it here
there's a lot exposition dumps this a
fair number of exposition dumps in the
book as well but honestly exposition
dumps tend to read better on text than
they do in film because when a kid when
an actor has to say these things and try
and make it sound like natural dialogue
it kind of highlights that you're just
getting exposition depth on you getting
to read it it flows a little more
naturally and in many ways this film was
approached very safely I mean just look
at the director I mean they got they got
Chris Columbus you don't hire Chris
Columbus because he has a unique
singular vision you hire Chris Columbus
because he's gonna shoot the script that
you give him and that's exactly what he
did he also has a decent amount of
experience working with kids so that was
that was probably part of the reason as
well but in a lot of ways this film to
look at it feels like it's working out
for checklist like what's the stuff that
is most iconic in the book that people
are gonna expect to see and is required
for the plot to work and then it just
kind of goes down a list and there are a
lot of jumps in time as
a result of that that feel like much
bigger jumps on film than they do in the
book I'm sorry I'm nailing down like
some of the hurdles and some of the
stumbling blocks and like like I said
I'm not sure that was really much of a
way around a lot of this stuff but there
are a couple of things that right off
the bat this thing nailed if there's a
superpower to this franchise as a whole
it's casting the casting is flawless not
every performance is flawless but I
think part of that has to do with the
fact that this is the first time these
actors are playing these roles having to
say these words and understand this
world you can hear even some of the very
good actors stumble over some of the
what are to them nonsense words and so
like the first time Maggie Smith says
the word muggles she like she pauses
right before saying the word whereas in
the natural flow of the sentence you
just barrel through that that word and
and I don't mean to single her out
there's plenty of that from plenty of
actors and so you do have a little bit
of that going on but everyone is still
cast very very well and I do include the
kids in that at this point in time
Rupert Grint as Ron probably gives the
most fun and natural feeling performance
I'm not sure that's necessarily because
he was a more natural actor at the time
I think probably I stood with the fact
that Ron gets the least amount of
exposition you know Hermione
delivers a lot of exposition and Harry
not necessarily spouting a lot of
exposition but he has to set up a lot of
exposition because he's the one getting
it spouted at him so he has a lot of
wooden set up lines so that other people
can then spout exposition at him you
know you can see how both Harry and
Hermione Emily Watson and Daniel
Radcliffe are sort of you can tell when
they go from a scene where they are
feeling the interaction and a scene
where they are just reading the lines
and again I don't mean to make that as a
criticism because again when you get
actors that young that's kind of gonna
be what ends up being the case and it
comes down to
much of the script are they stuck with
lines that like there's no way to make
this sound natural there are some actors
who actually can even with the clunky
exposition are able to smooth it out I
think the big one just being Hagrid like
Hagrid is the VIP of this first film cuz
everything he says and he says a lot of
nonsense and a lot of exposition he
makes it sound casual he makes it sound
conversational in a way that most of the
other actors can't do consistently yet
but again I'm prepared to forgive that
for the most part especially keeping in
mind that this this is his first go for
pretty much everybody involved one thing
that I had to baited whether or not I
was gonna bring this up but I thought
about it yeah
yeah I am some of the effects really
suck and here's the thing I was
reluctant to bring that up because I
knew people were gonna go dude the
effects are there almost twenty years
old at this point you know why are you
knocking them they were fine for the
time the thing is they weren't fine for
the time you know I know they weren't
fine for the time this one we came out
in 2001
you know else came out in 2001
fellowship with the rain the First Lord
of the Rings movie and do you know which
of those two had a higher budget Harry
Potter by 30 million it had a 30% higher
budget then the first order of the Rings
movie it doesn't look nearly as good
whenever it comes to green screen CGI
effects and the compositing of CGI
components
it just looks clunky and it's not
because they didn't have the money to
throw at it and they ought and they
obviously aren't skimping there's a lot
of very good-looking stuff here the
practical effects when they go practical
are terrific and the sets are great
costumes are wonderful and and like I
said I know the technology was better
than this because you look at things
like troll and the Centaur or the green
screen
on the Quidditch matches and it's it's
not good even for the time it was not
good and I have the distinct feeling
that what it was is they shrug their
shoulders and what the movies for kids
that it won't bother them we don't need
to do better than this
whereas Lord of the Rings they knew they
were gonna be dealing not only with
young people wanting a fantasy adventure
but with like longtime D&D nerds and
literary academics and like people who
were really gonna put them through the
ringer scrutiny wise I think Warner
Brothers and the Harry Potter folks they
figured this is good enough for kids now
things get better on the special effects
for it actually I would say almost
immediately to my memory we'll see when
I revisit the next one but like to my
memory effects work up better pretty
much right off the bat with the very
next sequel and then kept getting better
after that but this first one it's it's
not up to snuff
well let's come back to some of the
casting some of these actors I mentioned
the kids and all the kids are good and
they're all solid especially for their
first go with some very clunky lines
they get the job done although like I
feel bad yeah I feel really bad for any
line Daniel Radcliffe had to loop and
they had to do as a dub over later
because you can always pick those lines
out they are so wooden the worst is when
he's confronting Voldemort at the very
end and like Voldemort
ghost or whatever like rises up and like
passes through him and Harry gets
knocked back and you hear I don't want
to be like he was 11 at the time and I
don't want to pick on him and I actually
the usual he's a pretty dang good actor
now boy
but that jumped out at me really badly
but with the adults and let's get back
to some of that amazing casting because
we have Maggie Smith who I mentioned and
she has a wonderful ease to the way that
she plays McGonagall you have
ah alan rickman that voice as Snape he
was perfect casting so so very good then
there's Richard Harris as Dumbledore and
you know I think obviously we get to
spend more time ultimately with Michael
Gambon as Dumbledore but Richard Curtis
brought a real he had a real twinkle in
his eye which I think was just a quality
he had as a human being but you can you
can hear like at this point in his life
his health wasn't great and he knew that
even when he took the role and you can
hear you know kind of a strain sometimes
but he still he still got that little
bit of mischievousness behind that and
despite the fact that liked it and this
is a supposition this is known that he
was basically blackmailed by his
grandkids to take this part they because
he said they wouldn't dogged him again
if he turned it down um he does seem to
be enjoying it I think maybe it's
because he knows that it's gonna make
you know his own grandkids happy maybe
that was what was fueling him but he
does seem to be happy to be there and
there's something just nice about that
even though there isn't honestly all
that much to his performance but there's
just a sweetness which is really what
Dumbledore needs to have especially in
these early stories because we need to
get why Harry idolizes him we need to
idolize them the way that Harry does you
know so that that can all get smashed
apart at later dates but let's not let's
not get ahead of ourselves but like is
that the casting is is the secret what
not not so secret weapon of this
franchise as a whole and from right out
of the gate all the Weasleys are
wonderful Draco Malfoy oh god he's so
slimy slimy little twerp he's really
really good for that tom felton and the
Dursley zouk richard griffiths and so
hateable another one we've lost i got to
see him on stage in Equus with daniel
radcliffe in london oh that was a good
but the original Harry Potter in a
vacuum looking at it completely on its
own as if it isn't kicking out for
franchise would just register is okay
but as a first step as a building block
as a foundational piece on which to
build later work it's actually really
good for that it is better as a piece of
foundation that it actually is as a film
unto itself if you're able to sort of
you know take the nostalgia goggles off
and look at it without having the Rose
tinted glasses on if we can do that it's
it's just it's fine it gets the job done
but the job that is getting done needed
to be done if anything better was ever
gonna come out of it later but I think
you know there's a reason when I'm like
I want to I feel like a little bit of a
Harry Potter movie I never pop this one
in but that'll wrap up this one folks so
if you want to support me there are
links to my patreon down below it is
much appreciated it helps support the
show and helps me cover my bills
there's the like button that's a huge
help folks been hitting that lately and
I appreciate it you can subscribe
there's a links below that for my book
and for merch whatever you want to do
there's stuff down there to do and
explore and click or you also don't have
to I mean I end of the day folks you're
the council just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned swish and flick
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]